week for um Hogwarts Legacy despite you
know the controversy around it I know
attic you stream the game you played the
game so you know what's your thoughts
this is your topic
it's a good game I think that people
you know even with all the the stuff
that's going on with it that this game
is it's gonna break records I think
this is definitely a game of the air
Contender uh depending on what's
currently out now now I don't know how
starfield's gonna end up or Spider-Man
but I'd be very surprised if I didn't
see this as a nominee at the interview
um and you know it might even win
because Starfield and them are good but
this got that Harry Potter name behind
and people I'm seeing another thing I'm
seeing a lot of women are playing this
game too uh you know it's it's
interesting it's interesting the way
things are going it's interesting how
many people are playing this on Steam
because they generally drop stuff really
fast and it's been like that for